hello guys welcome to today's just for
rookies class my name is Darius and I'm
gonna be talking today about an opening
that is very interesting these two very
straightforward very often very
straightforward in attacking play where
when playing with white you can obtain a
very very good position and very
aggressive position but basically can
put a lot of problems for your opponent
this opening has been popularized by
Robert James Fischer former world
champion and enable dis opening is Kings
Indian attack and basically you can use
it with white from many move orders so
it's very Universal and you can
get very good attacking positions in it
and especially you know if you are a
rookie in chess
basically it can bring you lots of lots
of ways I remember when at some point
eyes that I saw employing this as a kid
and I got to in lots of games with this
opening we will talk about my games but
more like case that I used to learn when
I when I was telling this opening
initially so let's get started
this is Kings Indian attack opening and
let's see how it can first of all how it
can appear on the board before you start
with E for also you can start of 99f
references I have three d v g3 nine f6
Bishop g2 is six short Castle Bishop e7
d3 short Castle Knight Billy to c5 e 496
and this is a position we are aiming for
with white want to position we're aiming
for with white and let's see what other
move order this position can come up
from starting from beginning efore know
that I frequently for let's say e 6 d3
normally you play d4 but like what we
try to get to commence the attack which
is d3 d5 92 96 98 ignite g3 c5 let's say
G 3 knight c6 Bishop g2 we should be
seven shortcuts offshore Castle again we
got the same position and here from here
basically we'll discuss in a moment what
happens next
let's and but let's see another move
order which is possible to get the same
position about this operative from his
opening let's say if for again first
movie for c5 Knight of 3 is 6 and now
not typical default but d3 we just love
surprising maybe but this is the entire
point of this opening and to get this
King's new attack let's say d5
9 BD 2 9 c 6 g 3 9 f 6 Bishop g2 Bishop
e7 short castle castle again we get we
got the same position and it is so
therefore you know it can come up from
many move orders so it's very Universal
and we if you are playing with white it
can be really really good an opening
idea to have in mind so I'm gonna show
many many games played by Robert James
Fisher here but also some modern games
by a modern grandmasters so let's see
how what are the main ideas is opening
basically in short white tried to create
a King side attack that's why it's sort
of Kings Indian attack why try to white
tries to emerge the Queen an attack on
blacks King and directly get some
activity and create some magic threats
and basically try to mate on the King
side in short so let's see what are the
possible possible scenarios what can
happen if you are playing at this
opening with white and and will black
how black can react to this so let's go
from very very beginning if for c5 let's
say that the 3 e 6 D 3 let's say yeah
let's say from this position here there
are several set of the black can react
you first setup is of course what we
already mentioned 96 or d5 to say 92 93
96 and lemma should be 7 and short
Castle is one setup the same setup is
possible also with postponing shortcuts
about playing pieces and maybe hoping
for low castle this is another possible
setup next setup is by playing here
Bishop d6 nabi shorty 297 idea of the
service basically as we will see here in
this position very often white push the
point with 597 and rook e1 and then try
to
create a king attack on the Kings I will
see this in a moment
therefore this idea of system Bishop d6
here and Bishop g2 now g7 is the to stop
f5 basically right now if I was
impossible simply because it's probably
simply lost so that's the that's that
point that you can't play really if I've
because 1985 happens and the black is
doing great so this is one other set up
another set of a possible for black I'm
not trying to cover all of them today
because possibly even more than I try to
cover in this lecture
however I cover more than enough for you
for you to kind of like be feeling
comfortable playing it on your own other
set of possible is basically to avoid
playing with Bishop e7 develop into e7
or g6 but developing it to g7 by playing
Jesus of g7 so that's in 86 g3 for
instance g6 Bishop g2 Bishop g7
shaq-asso Nagi 7 and we'll cover the
setup as well other possible setup is to
still develop a shot to e7 but try to
postpone playing d5 and this is also
very interesting and because then we
don't have if I which is our main idea
usually but this only allows different
ideas and we'll see one game of Robert
James Fisher how a beautifully one in
1957 and I think the holes are the main
setups what black can do here so let's
just get started and see what happens
after each of them so as I wrote the
most typical one is 83 d5 in IBD to 96
g3 9 f6 Bishop g2 Bishop e7 short castle
short castle this is the most popular
setup used by employed by many
grandmasters
and I think lately has been a very very
popular and but on the other hand it's
quite dangerous for black to play like
this simply because it allows white to
immediately push a poem to e5 and the
gains are space and then try to create a
inside attack and this attack is very
straight forward so you can easily
follow what Grand Master's are doing
here and basically a little bit of
imagination level of communitive play
and you can just very likely win
therefore let's see what happens if 597
rook e1 and let's say here black has two
moves possible one of possible is Queen
c7
putting some pressure on the opponent if
I've because right now white black
attacks at this pawn only five three
times with the two knights and the Queen
the and white defense with the knight
and the rope only therefore the best
move right now is to play Queen e2 and
basically to add to add on a piece to
the final spot also 27 has its own
drawbacks and we'll get to that in a
second other possible move here is to
play b5 and try to create a very quick
Queen side active active play on four
black which is the main let's say
approach here so let's see what happens
after let me get to this position let's
let's see what happens after a be 5
because this is the most typical the
most classic approach and let's see what
kind of play white can have here nine of
one this tide comes to a fun next moves
are basically Bishop f4 h4 night h2
because Paul it for performative over a
to h4 and then very likely play h5 and
h6
maybe bring the Knight to g4 sometimes
also
95 or maybe Bishop g5 and developing the
queen as well basically shifting all the
attention to the Queen side to come into
the Kings side where white can basically
create mating attack hopefully so this
is the main idea and looks very
straightforward because it seems like
there is nothing black can do to stop
that so that's why I think it's a really
good opening if you just begin to play
chess and to have in mind because it's
very simple you and you can very quickly
create mating attack and win games with
which ultimately is the main sort of
goal to win the win games right so this
seems like very very natural way of
developing an attack also in if you've
played this you need to find very
competitive play and develops your
tactical skills as well so many benefits
of playing is opening therefore let's
see what happens and first I'm gonna
show maybe one game of Garry Kasparov
what happened after moved his open
played here Ruby which is a little bit
of a sideline because normally you play
a five but let's see how I react as part
of one
one here his game because even garlic as
part of employed is opening h4p star of
84 developing the building up on the
aching King side attack black could use
before night h2 very logical as I said
during this night to h20 ng for a 5 H 5
there we go
h6 is follow h6 it could be a threat
let's say and right now if black plays
simply a 4y or a can push h6 and this
already put some pressure on black
because for instance if g6 this probably
Spartan f6 could be potentially very
very weak so let me just show some
scenario of what might have mod 1 what
might happen if black don't react well
here let's energy for we shot a 6
we should f4 is just sample variation
which don't necessarily would the best
thing that black can do but this is one
of the scenarios because it is a heart
attack I saw that can be very hard to
face that's a Quimby 622 maybe look see
it seems like natural developing moves
Bishop g5 suddenly if what traits this
Bishop was bishops bonus is far enough
seeds would be very very weak and if
what Queen can get to there with pot
support of 106 would be this scheme
would be very big danger so far is let's
look what what what can happen let's say
black play some something like for
instance I'm not sure but let's say
black play something like Bishop b5
which is not a great move doesn't really
lead anywhere but you know maybe black
goes to something like this let's say we
should take c7 90 x e7 Queen g5 let's
see nice e6 back because he now goes on
their attack it's not the best play but
it's possible Knight f6 Knight f6 Queen
takes f6
suddenly 27 is already mating maybe one
fret so the only move to prevent that is
now King f8 after 9 g5 for instance
feeding again Queen f7 mate
so if Queen c7 protecting here suddenly
white can play Knight takes c6
and black cannot cap recapture back
because there will be check on for the
King on the way and white already
basically wins and this is the very
straightforward idea that the White has
here in mind when playing his opening
basically try to get to h6 exploits the
f6 Square and build up an attack and
just win basically go for mating attack
therefore this is what would make happen
if you allow to push this pawn white
pawn to h6 black on the other hand can
stop the others in the Kasparov's game
after h5 to play h6 themselves but this
opens up another possibilities because
as you can see right now Bishop is very
very
I know England see one because it puts
some pressure on lipsticks and it opens
sort of possibilities of sacrificing the
pieces on h16 opening black skin so
let's see how Kasparov make made use of
that a chief for already white attacks
on h6 twice and it's not so easy to
react to this because then issues could
be could happen basically any moment so
his opponent as far as open play for a
free no the bad move basically stops
activity of on the quizzes of of black
text a rook takes 96 Bishop f4
sympathetics on it night x h6 doesn't
really run away yet so there is no need
for that c4 and right now what is very
interesting as part of just ignore the
rook on a free and lipid d4
Bishop takes a freebie takes a free and
the idea behind it is that without this
Bishop on e7 look in this position with
this Bishop on e7 this Bishop sort of
helps would defend many many lines after
we shot X a freebie takes a three if
this picture is not there anymore we
didn't really look to only free to
attack on a queen size a king side so by
this temporary may be temporary but like
this post sacrifice exchange a section
exchange sacrifice we increase our
pressure on the King side so let's see
what Kara how Kasparov won the game
because he played this event between 87
Quincy one building up on sacrifice 186
C free maybe idea is night C for Queen
a3 and if black will be able to do it in
time would be obviously great for
instance let's say if King H talk let's
see for King gauge you want some random
most queen a free and already black is
doing right here because the attacking
spawn for free and offering to trade
Queens
getting some time Ori black is doing
great here however of course
is very concrete game and after
inserting of legacy free having all
those pieces concentrate on a kingside
as far as the Stars winning attack
so finally we should take 36 very strong
move
she takes h6 Quinta's h6 white an entire
the whole rope down but the skink on g8
is a is in big danger already Knight f6
is a tremendous threat and basically if
white can play Knight of 6 will be just
made there is no no way of stopping up
there fork is up on a plate of 6 himself
trying to stop Knight f6 but there is no
no salvation here anymore because just
takes on f6 Queen h7 Queen g5 check King
gauge 8 and other night comes into the
joins the attack move Knight h4 and this
night comes to g6 we should this ever
happen in the game 96 key mediate Knight
h6 and this is game over this here
caspere's Oakland resigned so which is
pretty much normal because this is
already just made here basically my in
few moves at least Queen a tweet x h6 is
for squid I said she just wins the Queen
there for white just by sacrificing
initially in exchange then sacrificing a
bishop on h6 create white credit very
strong guy like that was basically
irresistible this is so this basically
how you can win in this opening because
it is already complicated if you think
about it just basically you are throwing
in pieces to the king side and you just
create fresh and you suddenly black
cannot defend and yes grandmasters may
find some defense yes but like it's
still very hard and it's very it's
considered as the one of the most
dangerous openings that white can employ
again again for
when playing let's say in math with
situations or not any situation
basically you just need to can employ
you either looking for very aggressive
and competitive play and like Casper who
can win just like that if that makes
just one simple ones one small mistake
looking at this game it was pretty much
I'm clear where even black made a
mistake because it seems like all the
moves were pretty much natural but the
way the game well is just crushing so
let's see what black else can do and to
how what white can do then let's come
back to this main position and not let's
not play rugby eight what Houston
Kasparov game but let's see one game of
Fisher a five which is also very natural
h4 again h4 before Bishop f4 a4 a3 be
text yes every is very actually for
important move because this is in
Kasparov game this moves this move
stopping black of activity on the Queen
side and gives some additional time for
white to create some attack on a queen
on the King side therefore F is actually
useful to play we takes a freebie takes
a free roof f3 is here not as great as
earlier because ball is not yet on h6 so
small exchange sacrifice may not be that
great but we take say free makes perfect
sense Knight a5 other both possible with
Bishop a6 which leads to similar
positions however is more accurate and
but you can basically try to employ same
strategy as Fischer employed in his game
and blacks task is not easy
therefore let's see would have an in
Fishers game a 95 93 si si dice Knight
can go through if 324 sometimes from h2
to g4 but basically this night will not
to g4 square and either way if it gets
there it's great so let's see
how how fish would Fisher did 93 we
should pay six fish average free with
possible also 94 was possible not sure
which was actually better but I like
what the official was doing so much free
before night f1 it's also possible right
now to move back however I see more I
feel mapping a little bit more accurate
was 94 just following the idea but I
don't want doesn't spoil anything
because right now this with after d4
this move sort of weakens to see first
square and design may come also here so
it's it's very subtle but Angie for Evo
just want to follow typical plan you can
easily do it but anyway the game of
Fischer here is also instructive so he
painted of 1 & b6 logical coming to d5
and right on our g5 and honestly now
idea is a little bit different because
most pieces here seems like all the
moves were pretty much natural for black
but most piece are misplaced and white
create immediate attack with 95 and
hoping to bring the Queen to h5 for
instance after h6 Queen h5 may follow
and after h2 h3 5 H 2 s g5 a weed we are
not afraid to sacrifice a piece because
right now we can maybe swing the rope to
h5 maybe somehow remove the knife from
f1 King from g1 and play rock h1 or we
can through a swinger approve the for
Frank to 84 84 and hopefully give me 2
blacks King because of this opened edge
file which is to be honest very likely
scenario here
it's worth it's good to know such ideas
let's say a white can move the knight
from Judy talking to G to the rook h1 in
case of some check of the diagonal let's
just make some random moves let's play a
95 maybe first of orders move 96
possible which already creates very very
strong as possible
why the black is winning but just to
show the typical ideas here I just want
to show that this manoeuvre of the
Brooks wing is very likely good as well
Kimmy tree - maybe Ruby - back continues
it's their play another gauge one less
wrote XC - and suddenly could be
someone's like Bishop e6 or Bishop f5
anywhere special moves and because of
this battery of the rook and the Queen
suddenly there could be a maid on the
edge father said Bishop f5 already and
it there is no sway to stop the mate
because Queen any giant rock we need
seven his next and thus Queen and the
king is basically just being made one of
the possible ideas here therefore h6 was
not played in the game he features open
played 95 first Bishop d2 preserving the
bishop which is the HD 5 Bishop 2 HD 5
because this 9 g5 does lots of damage
and causes lots of trouble here for
black that's why at some point like say
just to take it which is logical
Bishop Taguchi 527 Queen h5 again Queen
comes to h5 building some some attack
here rook FC 892 as I said earlier this
Knight from f1 after D for most players
and possibility of coming to d2 and to
e4 and was creating more frats Knight c3
Bishop f6 very important move it's also
very nice moved to have in mind because
it's maybe not into intuitive basically
- just to play absorb f6 and the sort of
plan turret
it's not really a blunder obviously
because it's temporary sacrifice maybe
not temporary but sacrifice because
after takes takes this King again we'll
be in big danger because some for
example Queenie 627 is already made into
threat or Queen g5
27 a queen
and kicking the basically putting some
real pressure big pressure on the black
skin so it's very dangerous attack so
you can think about such moves also if
the knight was already only four who
could be possible to play also sacrifice
the knight on f6 it's typical idea in
most positions basically you just you
are not afraid to sacrifice a piece or
even two pieces in order to just to
really
try to make your opening skin so Bishop
f6 very strong move by official Queen e8
trying to defend 94 the ideas of the
quinny-quinn g5 to innovate just trying
to hold somehow but future just brings
another piece another piece and the idea
is if he black would take this Knight
rook takes obviously and rook is
swinging to g4 again for the for Frank
this time but the rook also joins the
attack so he's up on a few shots of anti
g6 queen g5 queen h6 a queen of 8 and
queen we have to anyway run away there
425 played by Fisher makes perfect sense
Knight exit for roof tech c4 c4 h5 right
now rook swings to h4 and white anyway
opens the H file without even having to
sacrifice a piece C takes D free visual
just ignores even the pollen D free and
the space book h4 just goes for mate
Brooke a7 hoping to kind of defend or
like maybe from lack of ideas just
played rogue a7 trying to hold somehow
Bishop g2 D takes c4 de éxito Queen h6
threatening mate in one
Queen g7 Queen a fight and right now a
final move in the game I would like to I
would like you guys to take a second to
think about before I show it
okay if you guys haven't found it it's
okay but the the solution is very nice
is where I wanted to let you guys think
for a second if you found a great if not
don't worry quintics h7 is the mating
basically made in three moves one we
have many free moves a small tactical
idea after which fizzles opponent
Myanmar Saran resigned and the idea is
here that if King h7 pawn takes and if
King g8 the sukkah checkmate
if king 36 we should before mate so
sorry sacrificing a queen also by
building up the attack is also possible
in this opening also in many many
positions where you build very strong a
targets with one of their ideas very
nice game by Fischer and shows was the
potential of an attack in this Kings
Indian attack opening all right so let's
get the back little bit and let's let's
talk about this position because
sometimes you know okay some let's say
black white black sides with a four I'm
gonna show right now a little bit modern
game and how those ideas can be employed
in this opening we should okay freeze
okay quick and Queen c7 bishop before
and as I said earlier if Queen c7 is
very logical but it has its own
drawbacks and we'll see right now in
mother game by played by Ahmed ugly from
2017 what what is the drawback of Queen
c7 move and how white can make use of
this coming back to play her in black
played Queen c7 already
Bishop e7 Knight f3 and as I said this
night very often comes to g4 through
either f1f1 for either h2 or e3 but we
know c7
there is additional idea that white can
use in order to
build some idea build some attack here
so let's see what happens because rogue
FC it seems like very natural move
played by Ahmed Ali's opponent ruk FC 8
developing the rook may be playing the
plank opening the C file at some point
making use of the vastu they placed
before at some point making use of those
pieces here focus on the C file if Black
gets to open the C file that position be
great
possibly not really because all depends
is still far a long way to opening the
sefa but potentially could be good but
in this position heavy boots queen of c7
which is actually badly placed white has
additional tactical idea and this is
what ahmed ali makes very good use of
Knight takes d5 temporarily set aside a
sacrificing a knight and after a text e5
e6 opening the diagonal opening this
bishop because this bishop right now is
the queen and also by advancing this
pawn what he hit this 997 suddenly white
position open M is very good position
opens at the center and blacks pieces
are all folks on the Queen side and
forgot sort of on the center and let's
see how ahmed ali beautifully won't game
in only 21 moves which this shows a
little bit different idea what this 95
is sort of thing that you should
remember that exists unless if the queen
is on c7 hashanah for Bishop d6 takes
thanks takes 27 23 795 suddenly all
those pieces are focused on the Queen
side while King on g8 on a king's is
completely the
and less without any defense basically
only four spawns which are doing good
job so far but it positions pretty much
very dangerous because there if the
night for instance this night from c6
was actually on f6 blacks position would
be great but there are c6 this king is
in big in big danger so let's see what
happened the game because the game s is
only two more moves which is astonishing
also than g5 it creates multiple threats
one fresh spinach five our friends
provide free possibly because this
diagonal is opened and it could be a
good thing for white to play include be
sure which for in terror attack
Rudy eight rang with the rook from this
dagger Queen h5 very logical first index
h7 Queen a5 and right now I'm not going
to ask you guys to find this move but
when I would when I found this game I
was simply astonished by this move
because after this move
what simply wins and at least opponent
just resigned and this move is rook is
six sort of voluntarily giving the rook
yes but right now this Queen sort of has
very little squares because this queen
is forced to defense of this pawn on h7
it's kind of like it's stuck I mean if
the squeeze could be kicked out somehow
the spoon of you even if white then can
take on h7 white simply wins because
will be some mating attack but let's say
after Bishop h3 here is not releasing
value sure it free black stones can
still call we move like Queen g6
therefore group is six move takes
control in issuer the takes control over
the g6 at first and let's say after F
takes is six what having happened next
is Bishop h3
and right now this bishop comes to h3
and Aipom only six and queen on f5 are
both under attack because night from g5
also supports like hitting on e6 and if
Queen moves that say here Queen Jesus
turns to protect this pawn we should eat
six fall off and if King f8 simply night
x h7 and the screen is drop because
everything comes with check so and I
it's basically it because after let's
say I mean almost anything Bishop e6
just follows and there is no no defense
from that and here we should be six
let's say King a trade it's possible to
play for instance knight of seven after
King g8 let at least night expiate at
least night xd8
basically then after King AJ one of the
possible moves is just to trade quest
take an IP server and just pink left
with the piece up so that came over
basically after is six two exclamation
marks easily I can Holly just won the
game right on the spot and his opponent
just resigned didn't see a reason to
continue the game he just resigned which
is very very instructive and also very
beautiful so let's so this would be it
for the almost eight let's say for this
line of I want to show quickly one more
game of Fischer how he won in this
opening I'm in this line where say we
should be sensei after 27 if five again
97 Queen e2 this is what I said this
what he said earlier that right now we
have to defend this pawn on e5 because
the his was attacked three times and we
are definitely twice
we weren't thinking only twice that's
why we need to is sort of must in order
to put some more defensive resources to
protect spawn in five but as we had also
earlier this Queen on c7 is misplaced in
manualized as this Bishop comes to it
for the OB distension on this diagonal
and if the spawn on from ec's could be
removed
there could be some issues as the game
of Ahmed oddly the with the the one and
overcooked a rookie six-month so that's
what happened Fischer's game be five
let's say H four nine five nine f 194
which is under let's say typical move
because night to d4 if night 94
basically forces one night one pair of
lines to be traded on the other hand it
messes up black's pawn structure because
pontiff or could be a weakness in the in
the future but let's see what happens in
Fishers game is about four rupees six
knowledge to rook c6 where it seems like
very very smart idea to break through
six a hit on the spawn stick to write
okay Roxy one and right now black played
wanted to basically increase the
pressure on c2 by playing Bishop a
65-year rook c8 and putting even more
pressure on c2 and this is very logical
move but it fails tactically again two
very similar idea as in the Ahmed Ali
A's game we should takes d5 this time we
are we're not sacrificing and Bishop on
the knight on d5 at Bishop and the Civil
Guards it AZ v e6 queen dat takes d7
sorry Queen takes seven Queen Texas and
white wins the piece rocky six Queen
three four five let's say I was in the
game Queen h5 index 7 9 f3 and suddenly
white is just simply much much much
better here and because this Bishop on
Isis is completely out
doesn't participate in the game neither
Poland before is under attack from this
night in very it's very likely that will
follow route 86 and rook e1 and white
wolf controller FL so strategically
White has all the strengths and quite is
clearly clearly in charge here you can
happen g6 I'll just quickly see how the
game followed HD screen h6
we shall f6 rook takes f6 quint x e6
smart move Bishop e5 because after
middle XE v rook e1 pinning and
regaining the bishop back for rook takes
e5 27 h5 continuing the attack F takes G
3 + H 2 X 3 6 ignoring the genetics of 2
because just context of 2 and position
is too unequal material but is
definitely white who has a very strong
attack here
h6 d 6.36 quincy server and various nice
tactical idea or 3 5 basically forest in
quintic g6 at this moment a gather
reside Fischer visually the game feature
color finished and because after quit h6
rook takes g6 there is a track and also
bishop on e6 is under attack it's double
attack and white wins the piece and just
came over and if what black does Prince
plays rook f7 then there is move like
Queen h5 or group 26 also possible
create riots good enough as well and
there simply pin and white wins the
Queen and that's game over
so again with the Queen sister you have
to look out for both ideas of
sacrificing on d5 and playing ecigs
because there are very very common and
they can happen basically very often
let's let's see some different setup for
for
for a white if for black of what black
can do let's say here b6 in this
position because it's the main position
sort of if black plays b6 try to be
smart and prefer and not to play a short
Castle yet let's say we should okay one
we should be 7c free is what the
possible moves Queen c7 we need to sort
of like it's possible to it's possible
to wait we'll move e5 until black plays
short Castle because if we play e5
immediately does the entire blacks point
here you play e5 the 97 is already
blocked in the center and White's King
blacks King doesn't have to go to the
short side there is possibility that
after 91 okay if short castle would be
great because we can canoe our key say
attack but if but the thing is the keys
in the silver center that's why kids
quizzes ever can be played the same shot
before and long castle and this and him
here black squeaking on a queen side is
much safer on a king side and that's the
point of sort of delaying castle so
let's see what white can do in order to
[Music]
basically prepare and anticipate what on
what black spam we should be 73 that's a
quiz havoc we need to still waiting with
E 5 which is very important and
instructive and right now it appears
that after Locke has to be if because
blacks arm is to make this go shock us
or no Castle because all these are
playing so naturally moves either short
or long Castle
if long Castle suddenly white creates
why don't push if 5 again I just placed
a three with the next before and
suddenly quick King concede is not so
safe anymore
any black place before opens Queen side
and opens new sort of
site for white to attack and white is
just simply better here circum display
next move before open the queenside and
create very strong katakana blacks King
that's why low castle is not so great in
here and any short castle again as as I
think you guessed it a five
because if short as we always do a five
if only we can and we create king-sized
King side attack and let's see one game
of America era that he played against
Surya Ganguly in 2017 which was I will I
know this game was really impressed by
it 97 h4 b-59 f1 seems like all natural
moves before again
seems like all natural moves before
expand on the queenside h5 white also
following the plan of creating the
putting upon 2 H 6 BC BC we shall basics
again if h6 there are all those ideas
connected with night h2 let's say in 94
and asana Kasparov's game basically
sacrifice this African h6 that's always
dangerous play h6 but if Bishop h6 white
can play h6 g6 and Bishop f4 and it's
going ported to have in mind because the
squamous is easy on c7 the right is up
93 9 XD 5 sometimes if this tactically
works you have to always consider that
but in this game a ganguly play Queen a
581d to Lucchesi one logical c4 and in
here we always try to close the center
because with close center we have our
chances of creating attack are much
larger rather than win open Center
because with open Center black can
create encounter play after c-44 white
what his big advantage of my pian Ruka
bishop a free
Brooksie - it was also possible probably
to sacrifice his exchange but there is
no need for that rook e8 Knight g5 we
shall provide Knight e3 simply bring all
the pieces the King side into the center
rook a b8 and 1985 company in the game
it takes d5 d6 and right of the screen
not all c7 that's true but we have such
a strong attack here that we can just
sacrifice the piece there and for a
cycle open in the center and planky 6
getting to blacks King so that ideas
also aggressive always good to know them
f5 and right now very nice idea by by
Hera
eat xd7 even sacrifices a queen rotates
it took Brooke Taney - and suddenly the
0 comes to e8 and pollo defies very very
weak as well as Queens sort of forced to
defend this pawn here and it's
impossible simply to defend it anymore
group b7 trying to hit this point 7
Bishop d6 nice because if Bishop d6
they'll be made in after rook e8 Bishop
available t8 intensified and rookie m8
very nice right
White is a drag queen down and still
wins if rook takes d7 we should activate
the Queen takes c3 and now just Bishop
d6 will happen in the game and wish of
the fibers coming rook e8 is coming
irresistible attack and story on
Gulliver stronger master from India had
to resign and the very very instructive
game and shows attacking potential of
what white of white in this opening
let's very quickly look at the
differences because also are less
popular however they still make happen
let's say in here if play white black
plays Bishop d6 Bishop g2 97 short
Castle short castle and here
it was very classy very long very long
time ago play the game by Fisher again
and let's see this game and here he
played at age 4 is good idea is good in
idea to know this because the next the
idea of this movie is to play F 4 and
after b6f for detects if or happen in
the game other with possible purpose
move is f 6 which is probably better but
rook e1 for instance and there goes some
some game goes on I would say it's
probably the best book black can do
however it's not clear whether black and
full equalize here but for instance one
of the possible ideas is creating
different type of attack because playing
f6 using the system opens gates to
different attack was let's quickly have
a look at game of I mean button modern
specialist of the topic Queen c7 c3
Bishop d7 93 we should be 8 seems like
natural moves Queen to Bishop h5 Bishop
h3 hitting only 6 e 5 and suddenly g4
Bishop f7 f5 and then very quickly g5 is
likely to follow and White has very very
strong attack here otherwise it's just
much better and it's one of the possible
follow-ups of the wall ok what can
happen here in this happen actually in a
game of Grandmaster
I mean Bassam and he won't very nicely
disk his game let's not we don't have to
look at this game and in total in we
don't have to see an entire game but
this until this moment is good notes a
idea exists other possibility is after
Knight h4 v 6f for let's say D tasty for
because if white will get to play e5 and
similar stuff may happen Queen h5 night
of Queen h5 o Queen h5 not
other would other airlines in the case
and then I did 395 for instance there
are possible who possibly have to attack
like that also it's possible to play
with maybe a little bit slower
just come back tonight and play h4 h5 as
well the cost center of possibilities of
the king-sized egg are much much higher
rather than move the open Center
so as I've been the the game vision if
cough happened takes before detects the
forfeiture by six hitting the road
rookie one c4 c3 Knight a5 a5 Bishop c5
King h1 95 94 and this is already
looking very promising for white but we
should be Samuel just Queen h5 97
already identify the big threat
similarly to what I discussed like few
minutes a few moments ago after a 7 just
g4 and threatening f5 white has
tremendous pressure so it's just let's
see let's just see how this game ended
because it's very instructive again
what kind of attack white can employ
here should I see 4 because design
Knight f6 could be very often sometimes
and I never have an idea so black has to
deal with it somehow
takes takes g6 Queen h6 95 and just
openly the Queen side of f5 f6 could be
afraid therefore root yet and if f16
Bishop effect but white simply opens the
Queen side F takes G 6 f2 h d6 and
simply just going for it 96 and this is
just wind it's impossible is not
possible to take it on g6 because winter
is physics and it's just winning cooking
available f1 for instance and made on
major next move on f7 or in few next
move if what like suspect show up to an
idol for if King a Jade Queen h7 made
there for game help 27 not just comes
back and not white only has
strong guitar but also is has a is upon
up material has material advantage
therefore position just box position
just collapsing Brook 88 9 h5 King gate
rate Knight f6 knife Anika six times the
pawn obviously Luke g8 which of the four
developing all the pieces through g4
brocade you want finally the last piece
comes to the game room the g8 f7 is
important to know that after Queen d1 we
don't take on d1 because we get mated
ourselves obviously but we play Queen h7
instead and we are mating black first so
this is a small small detail they want
to point out so this is this Bishop d6
9g Bishop g2 97 line let's finally
discussed some setup with knight c6 and
chief 6 which is or before we get there
let's quickly have a look at the game of
fissure which happened what what happens
if black goes for this system but tries
to avoid playing d5 let's say place 56
about 25 maybe the two again at this
pairing to 55 but let's say Ruby it
happens right now rook e1 was happening
the future serving in 1957 d6 c3b 654
and this is actually very important
because if black doesn't play this d5
white can play C 3 and D for them and
just control the center and this is the
what happened exactly
in fisherman c3b 64 it's important to
remember that if if black doesn't play
d5 doesn't fight for the center white
can simply play C 3 and d 4 and occupy
the center themselves and as would
Fisher did and very suitable he's a very
strong attack and
very nice game h'weezy seven happened if
five very strong move 95 and here
probably see for was even maybe a little
bit more accurate but he thinks this is
perfectly fine as well
what happened for Fischer played Bishop
to 86 94 bring the pieces to the
kingside c4 trying to have this 95
untouchable sort of because it can be
attacked with the Sephora move anymore
so after c4 death but this has this
drawback of 1986 Quinta xt6 and just 95
and again just going for the King side
attack very very strong very very
powerful play by efficient night c7
Quincey 207 96 and now again 84 both
ideas are very very similar in many
positions in from his opening even if
the structure is a little bit different
than in other positions so it's good to
know the general ideas also not maybe
not necessarily the exact move orders
but the ideas that you can follow and
use in your games 96 happened and now
very strong move Knight takes h7 and the
idea is that after night xh7 just h5 and
use making use of those pieces that are
in this place here and if the night
comes here we should up for simply and
the Rockies
local group falls from on b8 if King h7
shot of King h7 do we should look for
immediately same thing because right now
this knight is pinned and the bishop
type who like takes the next next move
of duruvan be 8 there is no way of
stopping that if 97 h v 9h for a now be
shot before Queen d8 but was important
right now official just ignores rockin
ba and just takes here which is much
more important Ruby 7 h6 continuing the
attack and this is already winning for
404 wide let's see how the game ended
which we need for takes takes root
before
we need five rookie three a five roof h3
28 Bishop e5 King is in big trouble here
there is no way to resist the attack
Knight of 6 Queen d2 Queen comes to h6
King f7 orbit or 5525 pinch also also
was possible here takes text to page 7
Queen takes f6 crew page 7 and Bishop c6
in case of group FC is just to quickly
show missed which a busy person is at
least possible at least and this is game
over which one missed six and this is
where serving resigned which are very
beautiful game and again beautiful
example of what attacking possibilities
what happened is opening finally let's
very briefly look at the system of g6
which is sorry G 6 which is less popular
I mean it's actually labeled as popular
Bishop e7 systems is why I left it as
the last however his ideas are pretty
much pretty much the same so let's see
what happens Bishop g2 Bishop g7 shot
castle 9 g7 and they're now c3 and
because again if black does not play d5
then c3 d4
is what white should do if like goals
defy then very very often white will
play for a 5 but so if d5 of course we
can tell if I immediately
simply because 95 just means the pond
but we can prepare by playing the p1 and
then after a shortage of the e5
for instance and here we have the same
set of ideas as we had earlier but in
even better version because white
already I mean black already played g6
and the pawn and have already very weak
spell on f6 and h6 and if this night
comes to the stage for further and
Knight comes to g4 eventually did I can
jump either here or here and what have
very strong attacking ideas this is only
the same thing but just better version
for a while earlier what we discussed
and if if five is possible to kind of
shift the direction it's possibly the
black shadow but it it's kind of weird
to play a signal underneath off so I
wouldn't worry about it too much
however possibly it's one of the would
black should do because after the shell
Castle white simply occupy city for a
dozen or fifty four and this is a game
again the game of Fisher after d6
he played this taxi five detects 5ku
Nieto and right now if I was coming and
we get same sort of position only thing
with what deep bombs but it doesn't
really matter much because the same
ideas apply only if only thing is even
better was bad for white the Dwight can
develop this night to be for so let's
let's look at a few moves what happened
the game a 501 which away six twenty
four ninety two just Queen h4 94s coming
very likely if this this and now a four
and yes we didn't go form it right now
but I encourage everyone to see at the
beautiful game Fisher draw from 1966
Havana not sure we have time to look at
this game because very long game but how
could you maybe show a few more moves
rook d7 whichever one takes takes and
right now the C 4 square is very weak
design comes before and White has very
very strong pressure in on the Queen
side and also in the center this Bishop
is misplaced and simply white have white
has very good chances to win this game
and Fischer beautifully converted his
strategy
strange in this position and he won't
eventually the game so I would suggest
really looking this game because it's
it's very instructive and just to
quickly show also what can happen after
I mean if Y to if black plays if black
after his divorce takes force it takes
before I mean after de for let's say
here black takes let's just quickly see
what happens if five but let's see let's
let's watch this game on the example
because I just are basically basically
the same so let's quickly look have a
look again at the game of Fischer from
1970 against Oscar panel this was a
little bit seemed a little bit different
but very small only for the differences
the degrees already only one not enough
1e5 Bishop d7 I see three rocks eh up at
four and again it's very straightforward
attacking game and I hope you will enjoy
it so let's just look and enjoy rooks t1
B 5 B 3 B 4 92 Bishop to 522 with 22 we
basically try to trade those bishops
because it's the only defender of blacks
King and then hopefully we can shift the
knight to f6 or g5 and Queen 2h 6 out of
12 of squares and try to mate somehow so
let's see how I'm fish are employed
balls ideas 96 3 4 a 5 I came white
attacks on the Queen side also black
attacks on a quiz I what I was on a King
side and here if you attack the King is
usually if you have two can attack the
King in fact that can be strong is
usually paired in the attack on the
Queen side if you are not acting the
King so let's see what happens Queen b6
h 4 9 p8 Bishop h6 as I said training
both bishops 9725 bringing more pieces
with c1 3 c1 which about 6 quintiles h6
rook c8 and again we are not afraid even
to trade here because he will just
continue that
even though black traded so many pieces
there the bug is still under tremendous
pressure here quindi 95 neither fight we
should be for very strong move basically
the idea is if pawn takes Knight takes
e4 and this Knight comes to have sale
and basically made a few moves so it's
good to remember such ideas as Bishop
before Queen g7 and this Queen 7 move
has its own drawback because I think
that 7 follows takes on g7 takes on g6
takes bishop logistics and again
destroying the the blacks Kings defense
Knight comes to h5 possibly 12 6 and
this just came over very very strong
attack in irresistible Knight g5 9 h
5ida 3 + computer 9h for kimchi free
just a few choice that's it takes Queen
Knight f6 King f7 Queen h7 and this is
where Oscar panel resigned because after
Queen King f8 there is Queen Jayde mate
so I hope you guys enjoyed the lecture
this opening is very very interesting
and it offers very strong attacking
possibilities if you if you only if you
only are given the chance and it's very
likely it's very likely that black will
go wrong because it's much easier to
attack rather than defend so if the
defense is hard and very often
grandmasters failed to find the correct
defense what kind of what attack can be
very very strong therefore I encourage
everyone to trying out this opening even
if you play other openings already you
can definitely try give it a try to this
one and
hopefully you would like and hopefully
you win many games with it just like
Fischer did just like many other
grandmasters and yeah so they'll be it
for today for me and I hope you guys
enjoyed it and see you next time thank
you